is
[Laughter]
[Music]
guys girls what's good what's going on
it is monday again monday again and we
are chillaxing in the studio as we do as
we do the bright lights are on the
camera's running the drinks are flowing
the audio is zooming everything is
feeling good and fine
thank you to every single person that
came out to see us on thursday we had a
blast it was good it was jokes it was uh
live and lavish and just a wonderful
experience we can't wait for the next
one so thank you for that guys
speaking of the next one
speaking of the next one guys we do have
a few more tickets left for our london
show in september folks
you have to come
it's it's literally anonymous it's
non-negotiable yeah yeah yeah it's gonna
fly off yeah it's gonna be sick we've
got people from the states flying over
we've got people from like germany
finland i've seen flying over we've got
people from dubai flying over fans are
coming from all over the globe to see
this show in september you guys have to
be there and i'm hearing people saying
they don't want to come from birmingham
i've seen people say you should do a
show in cambridge
now man you might fly down to london
real quick bro real quick it's not that
long it's literally get to london on the
29th of september and come vibe was a
vibe with us live facts it's gonna be
sick you've literally got no excuse
you've got ample amount of time to plan
your days and your journey yeah get it
done man get it done you had way more
opportunity than the people that came
the other day they had a few weeks
notice sucks and a [ __ ] cheap stream
and a train strike a nationwide train
strike
they should wide train strike but they
still showed up showed up and showed up
so come on guys
link is in the bio
um
grab a ticket today bring a significant
other a special friend bring someone
there's been chirps in galore about this
show as well there's gonna be there's
gonna be knocking boots yeah there's
gonna be man them holding hands that
i've never met before yeah yeah people
are gonna
people are gonna leave there in love i
see a guy post it today i repost it to
our story because he he dm'd us on
patreon so i think he said he's flying
out from dubai
just to come to the show
and um the thing that he's meeting there
he's never met yeah she he just met her
on patreon yeah and she said she's going
solo oh
so he wants to swap seats with someone
in her row yeah so you can sit next to
her yeah he's offering three
bags no back three bills three bills
he's three bills for his ticket yeah he
paid like 30 quid for it he's offering
three bills to swap seats
yeah that's easy money yeah mad
so um guys this is going to be a special
show your boys have had a taste for it
now yeah and now we know what to do
um so guys 29 september please show up
you have to be there please
tell a friend to tell a friend come and
see the show it's going to be sick um
and yeah link's in the description so
jump in buy a ticket right now uh if you
haven't do do go on there and it's sold
out while you're listening to this i'm
sorry but that's
your fault literally your fault you had
weeks you had weeks anyway
as usual guys
patreon.com
forward slash sheets and gigs is where
you're gonna get all the extra content
the stuff you're listening to right now
is 50 of what we're providing on a
weekly basis 50
that's embarrassing it is embarrassing
that's literally embarrassing step your
game up there's there's stories that you
just you're not understanding there's
references we're making you're not
you're not prisoned
whatsoever you're thinking i must not
have been paying attention that episode
you weren't there or adhd i was drifting
in and out i wanted everyone
i had it on in the background when i was
rising you weren't there you weren't
present yeah yeah arsenal are writing
jokes to stuff that you're not even
aware of yeah mum and there's people in
patreon making friends over
relationships there's chirps there's
relationships there's groups of girls
that are kekake
everything's popping off over on patreon
so get over there it's gonna cost you
three pound a month tempe a day run the
p guys run the p get on patreon
binge all the episodes from the last two
and a half years check us out every
thursday and uh join the community over
there because it is a great time also
guys if you are listening on spotify
apple podcast wherever you listen to
your uh podcast please give us a review
listen all the way through and tell a
friend to tell a friend
if you are watching us on youtube last
but not least please like the video if
you liked the video chop sitting in the
comments make sure you subscribe to the
channel and ring the notification bell
please and thank you and without any
further ado i'm going to head on over to
my co-pilot
my main man my best friend my brother in
arms
my sloppy top sunday oh my goodness bye
earthquakes hit us with a fun fact
please thank you very much so guys well
you i think you went through that in
record time like a little bit of it yeah
i know right i mean yeah yeah i was
impressed with myself i liked it i liked
it uh so guys the fun fact of the day
right guys uh so the fun fact of the day
is um you may have seen this a lot of
you may have seen this as well uh lad
makes 34k in a month by letting viewers
disrupt his sleep on live streams this
was my fun fact as well i'll say not for
this episode though i'll say something i
had it in my notes yeah mad mad i like
did you read the whole thing no all
right let me just um
let me give you guys a quick synopsis of
what i want
um so
it's from lad bibles mum wrote i'm
clearly in the wrong line of work
making big money whilst just laying
there in bed is a dream for many of us
but one tick tocker jakey bowen
has managed to make his to make this
reality by turning the act of sleeping
into an interactive game on tiktok
uh jk allows other users to interrupt
his sleep with a variety of methods and
a conte and the content creator has
turned sleepy into his full-time job to
carry out this bizarre streams
boehm has crafted a custom script that
analyzes specific phrases or prompts
with his live chat
once the correct prompt has been
discovered by his script
a new distraction can be deployed within
boehm's room and i'm going to show you
the video in a sec
speaking with business business insider
tick tock tick tock or sorry jk revealed
that he earns up to sometimes over 34k
for his antics it's seriously
life-changing money the first week i
made five thousand dollars
that's where i thought this is big and i
can do really crazy things
let me show you the video
that's 12 30 a.m 12 30 a.m he's just
trying to kick
no
who had i promise you
not how often does he do this
i'm assuming like a daily on a daily
weekend yeah if he's making 30 bags a
month yeah he's doing it every day yeah
he must be doing it daily yeah i'll die
that is um
encore i couldn't do such a thing i
didn't i lost
i need it
i i [ __ ] need it
no literally the thing is as well it's
all well and good
first of all okay props to him yeah
because that's a
that's a cool way to make money it's
very new it's it's difficult and like so
perhaps you're making big money doing
crazy [ __ ] that people didn't even think
was possible 10 years ago yeah now that
being said
if someone say said to me tomorrow if i
didn't know that was a thing yeah and
someone said to me tomorrow
i will give you 30 bags a month
for however long you can handle it
for you to
um let people disrupt your your sleep
as and when they please yeah so you're
in bed and literally they press a button
make a donation or whatever and then it
wakes you up
and you have to do every day
i would say no would you
would i yes
you're thinking i'm doing some back and
forth no i'm saying no i'm not doing it
i promise you i'm not doing it yeah fair
enough i'll be dying bro oh trust me i
know i know i'll be [ __ ] dying i'll
be the same bro i'll be the exactly i
can't
i hate waking up at like
obviously here's one there's a [ __ ]
thing like it's 12 30 they woke him up
to do some [ __ ] [ __ ] but i hate
waking up at like
not too early but also not too late like
like seven o'clock for example to go
piss and i struggle to go back to bed
sometimes it's so jarring so let alone
having to do this
wake you up at dick o'clock one o'clock
two a.m whatever constant constantly
every time they clock that you've just
fallen asleep bang
wake the [ __ ] up oh bro it got it
couldn't i actually don't think it's
every day he'd be in hospital
it can't be every day he'd be in
hospital he must just sleep through the
day
and deal with that [ __ ] all night
yeah i guess then is he really sleeping
then if he's sleeping during the day
but that's the thing but if he's or
trying to sleep yeah well i'm saying it
still works badly because if he's if he
is sleeping through the day and trying
to sleep in the evening like he's got no
luck he's still he's got no life yeah
he's got nothing he's lit you've got no
life he can't spend his money all this
money he's making he's just chilling
because he's probably going on amazon
buying more [ __ ] to distract him from
sleeping oh [ __ ] hell bro like
that's torture to me
that's literally what they do in torture
camps i just don't know what you said
yeah why i just don't know how
he even started this obviously he must
have had a platform i'm assuming he must
have had a platform wait which is doing
whatever live streaming
let me see if i can make money by doing
this he brought yeah it probably he's i
think like
i think what he's do if you get actually
get into that world i guarantee like
what he's doing is not that unique yeah
to be fair yeah i've seen yeah rabbit
hole type thing when they first
introduced lives to tick-tock and you
would just scroll through tick tock and
they'll be the lives on your stream i
never see lives anymore they just have
no interest but at first they were
pushing it yeah i would see a man making
money doing foolishness oh really fam
there was a prayer that was trying to do
trick shots with ping pong balls to get
it into a cup down a flight of stairs
and like bang it off and yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah and bro
people were just watching for hours
trying to get this [ __ ] in and i'm not
like i stayed there for like five
minutes
because it's interesting you're engaged
it's such useless content but it's
[ __ ] interesting yeah yeah yeah um so
yeah i reckon if you get deep into the
whole because then you've got like the
asmr kind of stuff people do you've got
well weird [ __ ] the asmr stuff will
never
was compute with me it's boring it just
doesn't i understand well the thing is i
think i understand the aspect of asmr in
terms of the gratification but it just
does nothing for me i can't just sit
there and act listen to i can't sound or
mouths or whatever there's noise it
doesn't do nothing it only works for me
if it's a painting and she's just in my
ear yeah that's different like she's
here yeah i'm saying yeah that's what
the only way it was this random [ __ ]
that's like
and she's like
or she plays something like yeah
it's like [ __ ] off are you feeling tired
today
just like this is [ __ ] [ __ ] off and
there's always like weird headphones
headphones i'm not wearing the
headphones shut up for that completely
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah none of that um so smart doesn't
work for me but look some people love it
yeah i love it but not for me um but
yeah fair play to that guy i'm probably
sure i'm not doing it but fair play to
him 34 bags a month i can play indeed um
before i get into what i wanted to talk
about um
as you guys can see
your boy got tatted up today sure
probably can they see it uh they'll be
able to see it going um
if they can't see us it's it's like it's
my thing yeah yeah
and also if you're listening and you're
intrigued obviously pause your thing and
go straight to the youtube so you can
look at it asap um
but yeah so if you've been with us for a
long time you will know
that i said
ages ago when we were in the early days
of this podcast is that
when i
quit my job
i will get a tattoo that is so obvious
that people just i'll get a non-horrible
tattoo yeah i've got a tattoo that i
will go to a job interview that you
can't hide
and they'll be like no
and this is like mcdonald's yeah and
they just don't care yeah but any like
respectable job they just won't have me
as i need to have that so that i know
that i no matter what even if i want to
get another job i just can't yeah i have
once i leave my job i have to leave um
so it that was like over a year ago now
but still uh today was the day i got it
um
yeah i went to
see
my boys over at making marks in
lemington spa have you ever been to
limited spa by the way um i want to say
yes but
probably not because um this is just a
quick backstory for those that guys that
already know we went to coventry uni and
lemmington spa is probably about 15 20
minutes
away from carriccini so every time i
used to go from london to cove or carve
to london
but i don't think i've ever gotten off
and being into lemmington bro i've i
might have had a bodybuilding show there
one time but it was in some draggy bits
i thought it was dead there i'm not glad
to bro i thought it was ends i went
there today to this [ __ ] um tattoo
shop
bro
i can't say a lot for the whole town
yeah but with this one road i was on
love it
a lot of it okay what was in like
cornwall or somewhere
it's just all like really like um
like chic shops like you know like shops
that sell only white t-shirts oh [ __ ] do
you know what i mean yeah those kind of
just like really like hipster shops like
it reminds me of um every time i hear
stuff like that i always think of two
things either shoreditch ends it reminds
you of shoreditch or like uh not on
there what's the place what's this place
in many uh northern quarter yeah bro
yeah it's very shorter stroke northern
quarter yeah but it's like
refined yeah so like it's very like so
the street that i was on it's like all
the buildings are like white okay it was
obviously a nice sunny day today as well
all the buildings are white everything's
clean but hipster but super clean not
like known like rustic [ __ ] it's just
all like
modern
new age yeah yeah it's just yeah it's
both
it's a renaissance ting gang okay yeah
yeah some new age renaissance thing okay
on the street and i've been thinking
damn this is not what i thought limited
spell was like
so um
went in there to see them
fam
i've said this every time i've got
tattoo but i promise you're not getting
another tattoo i want to get this
finished yeah but i don't think i can at
this point
unless i just get like a little
20-minute thing to cover my elbow
it's going to hurt on the elbow no it's
bone well it's bone but it's also
there's no nerves here but you can pinch
your skin as hard as you want you won't
feel it so this should be fine
um
this yeah my [ __ ] neck
who had
from usually when you get so when you
usually get tattooed yeah they start you
off and you're like you can feel it but
it just feels like as if i was like
scratching you like that it's just
annoying it hurts but it's not like ow
you wouldn't ever like
the first touch you wouldn't let it
touch you and you've never been out yeah
yeah yeah you'd just be like it does
hurt but it's whatever it's only when
they start going over the same bits
around the same area that you start
being like
this is really starting to [ __ ] hurt
like the neck
barrel so let me paint a picture for you
i had to get topless yeah
i'm like i had to lay down in the fetal
position yeah on his bed so i'm like
this and my back on his bed yeah on his
bed i have to get on his bed fat
lay in there and uh so
like this yeah and i'm laying like that
topless yeah breast out yeah the first
stroke yeah
i'm not gonna lie to this i was like
this i was like here we go he's are you
nervous i was like nah i'm not nervous
bro come on fam shut up do the thing
firm
the first stroke i grabbed that i
grabbed the bed like this
i was like i'm ready i'm ready like i
had to stop myself from jumping jerking
yeah because i was like [ __ ] that that
[ __ ] hurt immediately
did you make eye contact like that i was
just
because he had like this little board
here but it's like it was made out of
glass so i could see myself oh okay so i
was just looking at myself here i'm not
lying to you it wasn't a tear but a tear
came at my mom it wasn't like an
emotional tea but i took him out my eye
and i was there and i literally ever i
had to scratch it to make sure he didn't
see me yeah yeah he had to like scratch
it
and i was like [ __ ] yeah there's gonna
be like three hours of this oh [ __ ] he's
going going going and to do this like
black outline
i can't describe the pain
i can't describe it and he kept telling
me bro
it's gonna get better after this yeah
and i was like and when he said it
because he we were going for about half
an hour 40 minutes and i was thinking if
i'm all my head i'm thinking i don't
think i can do this
big man sing
i don't think i can do this
how's it going i don't know what i'm
gonna say you know what i'm gonna do but
i'm thinking i genuinely don't think i
can do this like this i can't continue
this i haven't felt pain like this in my
life like this is so bad yeah and then
he and he was like oh just i hadn't said
anything yeah he's like just let you
know the um
it's just it's just the out i'm just
doing the outlines yeah once i deal with
the outlines
it's going to get easier and then once
i've broken the skin you have this like
like pure alcohol thing but like once
you put that on it he's like it soothes
the skin down so that when i come at it
it's at least for another like half an
hour it's going to be less tender yeah
and we'll be able to go after it and
usually with the shading and stuff like
that that's always nicer than the deep
outliers and i've like this is a thick
black line like i've never had anything
like this like the worst i've had is
like this kind of stuff and that [ __ ]
hurt um and on the inside of my bicep
here
that [ __ ] hurt this was worse yeah
and then as soon as i've got about 30
more of these black lines to do and then
it's going to start getting charged head
fam
you're lucky you [ __ ] said that yeah
because i'm not lying to you i was ready
to walk out the door swinging this is
this is worse than i ever imagined it
would be yeah
and i was thinking bro i know it's been
like four years since i've had to uber
[ __ ] like i can't breathe yeah because i
was trying to i was on some wim hofting
i was trying to control my breathing i
was thinking if i just focus on my
breathing it's going to be fine i don't
know
and then like
you get like five six reps in and you
find
he finally
he finally
finished the black thing yeah and he's
oh let me put some of this this cooling
freshness [ __ ] on it
and then just as he's about to spray
he's like oh my sting a bit and i was
like what fam sprayed it it was cool and
refreshing i was like ah
the pain that started to like
bubble but
bubbles bubble the pain that started a
bubble
i sat up and screamed
i sat the [ __ ] up on a screen like the
barber side thing after you get a trip
barber side times a million oh my god i
was like [ __ ] hell bro there's
customers i said [ __ ] hell bro
and he was like i didn't want to say
anything but yeah it's bad as i thought
you said it's supposed to make it better
he said yeah it's it's the calm before
like it's yeah it's like it gets worse
before it gets better
like you're going to go through hell but
then once we go again it's going to feel
nice it wasn't lying after about 30
seconds it died down and it felt fresh
but [ __ ] healthy had
and then we lied back down
bro the pain was unbearable yeah this
was it hit me
this is where it got me so i'm lying
back down i'm traumatized
at this point i'm [ __ ] traumatized
yeah i lie back down into my fetal
position and he's like ah twist up so i
had to twist up and like face him a
little bit
and he's like over me here yeah and he
makes it worse because he's actually a
buff guy okay he's like a solid sixth
one yeah obviously tatted up yeah
shredded and big yeah he's a buff guy
okay white guy you're just typical am i
just the buffett's white guy you can
imagine him yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah um so i'm here
i said i'm here but i'm here and i'm
looking up thinking
i'm not making eye contact his head's
just here behind me and i'm thinking
[ __ ] and he's just going on doing the
waves and stuff like that and i'm
thinking this is a little bit better but
i'm still traumatized i'm still grabbing
the bed yeah for all my life yeah and i
just closed my eyes
and basically what they do when you get
a tattoo
is they'll do some drawing
and then they'll rinse it and wipe it so
they have this like um antiseptic water
or whatever then they'll just rinse it
wipe it carry on rinse it wipe it carry
on bro
as he's doing it we're probably like 25
minutes into the second like second
after the break yeah 25 minutes into the
second go and i'm i'm starting to not be
able to bear it anymore okay and i'm
thinking okay this is getting like
because what happens with the shading is
it's much nicer
at first but it's them going over the
same bit for ages yeah [ __ ] hell bro
after a while it gets so tender yeah and
you're like oh you need to move on you
need to move on but the worst thing is
because he's already
gone around the whole thing
even if he moves onto a new patch of
skin it's already tender tender yeah so
it's just like your brain thinks that
bits done and he goes back to it
oh my god oh
it takes you so i'm on edge yeah i'm
grabbing the bed i'm in the feet while
i'm grabbing the bed and i'm closing my
eyes yeah i'm thinking
family
he accidentally he picks up the bottle
to rinse yeah and one drip of the water
falls out the the the tip of the bottle
and lands like my middle of my back
[Laughter]
i'm laying here on my side i'm shaking
and this cold drip touches my back like
unbeknownst i said
i jumped
he was laughing bro and he's like you're
right
[Laughter]
i'm so used to trauma it literally felt
like
it felt like
when you're a prisoner of war yeah and
they've been torturing you
and you're so defeated
and then they just give you a little
flick and you're like stop you're
hanging
they've got you hanging
[Laughter]
that this little drop i didn't know what
he was doing to me
i didn't know what he was doing to me
i felt like i felt like a [ __ ] victim
oh my god let me drop my thing i said ah
[Laughter]
that's what i knew i was like i'm not
built for this yeah i'm not billed for
this yeah finish the thing and let me
out finish the [ __ ] thing and let me
out
[ __ ] me that's hilarious i'm never
getting a tattoo again that's hilarious
i have to but i don't want to
it was too much bro if you were there
you
you would have one been howling at me
yeah i'm too certified you're not
getting a tattoo really
[ __ ] man
[ __ ] i'm glad it's done though oh i'm
happy and i'm glad it was like a
one-session thing yeah yeah yeah because
it's not it's big but it's not massive
yeah it's not like the um yeah
so yeah um and your back one was that
one session
my back was one session
my next one session this
obviously still ongoing so far i've had
four sessions for this maybe five wow
and you started out over a decade ago
now oh i started this when i was like 20
yeah 21. literally just like oh maybe a
day yeah i think about 21.
yeah i think about 21 hours when i
started this and um
yeah bro it's still going i just need to
finish it and there's been three artists
that have worked on it
done yeah it's long but this has been
going sessions
and everyone i've been thinking what am
i doing here
every single one i thought what the [ __ ]
what am i doing what the [ __ ] am i doing
here this is not normal bro and then
there's people there like one of the
brothers that i met that works there
homeboy's got just tattoos on his face
bro it's just got tattoos all over his
neck and face i think it's one of them
ones where once you because they must
get them like so regularly
like they're just it's just numb to them
now i guess well i was chatting to
homeboy they did mine and he said he
hates it every time oh really he said he
hates it
but once you the thing is is what i can
see where it's coming from because like
i said every single time i've had a
tattoo i've always said i'm never
getting i've never ever gone through
that and i feel like it's similar to
like obviously
loosely like childbirth
because java is supposed to be one of
the most excruciating things any person
can experience but yet yes still having
babies babies yeah
and this like the human body has a way
to forget trauma yeah in a way that like
is unbelievable apparently they said
like if the human body is actually
trained into you like if the human
mind and body wasn't trained to be able
to like forget
pain and trauma yeah like we couldn't
exist as a species oh i'm not surprised
just because childbirth so bad that like
no one would have more than one
no one ever would have ever had more
than one um so same with tattoos like
you get one and you're like [ __ ] hell
i'm never getting that again and then
you get um and then a couple months this
heals
no pain it looks nice and you're like
how am i getting that might get another
way it wasn't that bad yeah
yeah
you started
it
convinced
it wasn't that bad i mean it hurt for a
bit but yeah
yeah it starts nothing okay again yeah
other side mistake yeah yeah but luckily
my happy is done but yeah that's it my
i actually did something i said i was
going to do
next up is the
um skydiving
[ __ ] illustrious skydiving
definitely going to book it um
i will [ __ ] book it yeah i'm going to
book it i'm going to book it i'm going
to book it going i'm just so scared
i'm probably more petrified than you are
you definitely are but yeah it is what
it is um anyway i've got some express
today okay
the eggs have been icking fam i'm not
even gonna lie
so let me find some
i'm just gonna i'm just gonna wet the
whistles with some of these today say
this wet the whistle
right so actually let me before i do the
eggs
let me drink let me breathe because fam
i'm gonna have a headache after laughing
at that series
okay i'm gonna have a [ __ ] headache
after laughing at some of these
that's what i'm here for
right she said
i sneezed and he said oopsie daisy bless
you
oopsy oopsy daisy
wow oopsie daisy just fam just
oopsie daisy bless you bless you
[ __ ] off yeah literally [ __ ] off no yeah
yeah get rid of your penis bro you won't
need that anymore yeah he definitely
wouldn't need that anymore oopsie daisy
oopsy daisy
during the deed he said
during the deed he said oh my goodness
the entire time
oh my goodness
oh my goodness
oh my goodness
safe
safe oh my goodness she would have been
perplexed perplexed bro and he was in
ecstasy
[Laughter]
oh god
oh my goodness
oh my goodness he should when he first
that's too slippy
it's too slippy and warm it doesn't make
sense
don't move don't move don't move
don't [ __ ] it don't you dare move oh my
goodness don't you move
oh my god them don't you moves
it's like i can't describe it it's like
there is literally a minefield in your
boxes yeah and it's the don't new moves
i don't think women take the don't you
move seriously
because they move more they they
yeah they live with it no you might not
understand
i'm
all right cool
so say this is the end of my tool yeah
and this is my body yeah this this is my
body
this is this is my body here this is the
tip of my tool and this is my body here
yeah
i'm in control yeah through all strokes
yeah i'm here yeah i'm ready
if i get you to a point where i say
don't move
it's here yeah and
i'm no longer in control of facts we
need it's like a t-rex
when literally they can't see you if you
don't move
so my tools on a t-rex thing because
it's it's on the hunt now
when it gets to the tip of the tool it's
on the hunt now literally any movement
any movement he's going to go off he's
going to go for the kill so shut the
[ __ ] up don't say anything and do not
move a muscle until it it curls back
into his leg until i'm back under
control
ladies when a man says don't move don't
[ __ ] move don't you dare move i know
you think it's all fun and games but he
will not and not in you
because he won't have time to pull out
he will not in you and now it's both of
our faults because the movement the exit
movement counts as movement so on the
way out he's not anymore he's nutting so
if a man hits you with the dumb you've
done we've done we've done over doing
that because he will say it more than
once yeah i'll let you know
don't move don't don't don't don't move
and you'll press your pelvis into the
bed don't move don't worry don't [ __ ]
sharpen don't move and we can carry on
this party yeah yeah oh sweets me
brother there is
all right oh bro
you'll feel this one oh god when his
door gets stuck on the carpet
for those of you that don't know this is
this is what me and food live with on a
weekly basis
this fridge and this rug oh they're not
boys they don't come inside what's up
there's no mesh there's numb
this fridge open is a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and we hate it i said they're not boys
but this one this one sweetened me
because i can't imagine a more feminine
experience
this is from a woman yeah when i'm
filling up the car and he's looking up
at me from the passenger window
firm man's just their leg i know the
knees are touching just
wow waiting to see if you'll stop on the
on the zeros
30 on the dot oh
and he's trying to cover conversation
through the window bro
yeah
yeah man man's walking down
bro this one's so specific
when they mmm their food more than once
that's it
[Laughter]
it's one of the ones where let's say i'm
back in this drink for example i back it
and i'm like and then i look at it like
like what actually is what's inside this
i need to look at the ingredients
because this is banging
but we've been there bear time
if you'll take me to any alchemist and
you get me something with smoke in it
i'll drink it and i just think it's
theater
i do
and i'll get that and i'll be like um
you'll double take that
you always have to double take yeah yeah
yeah you don't want to be on a date with
me at a cocktail spot
i'm one of your girls now
i'm one of your girls now
[Laughter]
when he has an umbrella in his boot
okay i saw that just in case i saw that
funny [ __ ] funny in hell
oh fam
when he rides a horse arse is just
bouncing
bro that's painful the imagery of that
is enough bro the imagery of that isn't
exactly imaginary it literally is he
looks like a power bottom
just throwing that ass back
he's a powerball bottom wow
he's throwing those cheeks back
stop
[Laughter]
wow oh my god
oh god this one this one in today's
society this one is very
like relevant
man said she turned my promotion story
into a lesson about the patriarchy
what
bro i already know how that conversation
would have gone it would have done
something along the lines of
i got a new promotion today
i'll really congrats who was in the
running it was me
rebecca sarah and shelley oh here we go
oh you got the promotion
over the three women oh cool yeah yeah
yeah yeah
cool the gender pay gap increases well
done you're contributing you're
anti-feminist and you're a piece of [ __ ]
oh my goodness yeah yeah
when he got um i've seen this one bear
when he goes into the coin section of
his wallet
that's
i saw one similar to that
she said something along the lines of
um when she realizes you've got change
in your pocket
might kind of have coins anymore they're
still coins mine can't have metal
anymore that's legal tender bro what am
i supposed to do just dash it
just
sees you've got change in your pocket
bro it's straight you know what the
worst one was when i was a kid
this is i didn't i was too young to have
a job but i already knew that it was a
thing
subconsciously yeah because i used to
have like a not a piggy bank but like a
coin thing in it
a piggy bank i just have a coin tip we
had the big [ __ ] off coca-cola yeah yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah so i had one that
actually was like it had like a
um what do you want to call it some i
think my mom bought it for me for my
birthday when i was a kid but it would
count your [ __ ] had like a calculator on
top and when you put the coin in
the distance it knows what coin it is
based on the distance that the the lever
has to move to push it in okay
so anyway it would count all your money
for you so you know how much is in there
sick so i used to take that [ __ ] down
to morrison's
empty and get there
it's the noisiest machine oh yeah right
on planet earth he used to take that
[ __ ] down to morrison's yeah and i
found sometimes i'd be 50 quid in there
oh mad and i'm like 14. yeah but bro the
nerves i had i used to walk in it i used
to put it in sandwich bags and just roll
up under my coat and just just pour it
and pull one in at a time as you're
walking
there like it's bear keys bro and then
you just get there look around just
and then when you're waiting he's like
chicken chicken chicken chicken
you're the only one standing in there
yeah it's the only bread shop
and you get you get your little receipt
yeah take it over to the the cigarette
counter yeah rama 47 pounds you fat and
19p yeah and the noses yeah you stupid
cow
[Laughter]
do you know where i am
oh my days were so embarrassing
right um
ah bro this one's annoying but valid
when he claims his free chicken at
nando's
ah
it's dread but
st
what else are you gonna do big man i've
i've got all the stuff the rewards i've
earned them let me munch
i don't get it
i just don't get it
they have reward cards for a reason
[ __ ] and i've got one and i want my
chicken i'm not gonna just keep paying
for chicken
run it to me wow oh my god ah bro this
one
it's happened to me so many times never
with a female but i can see why it's the
biggest ick yeah this is probably one of
the best ones i've ever heard okay when
the uber driver cancels the trip
and you're not you're not even there
he's gone from four minutes away to
cancelled
that's happened to me on numerous
occasions bare times always in london
for me numerous occasions fam oh
yeah let me just pat this on uber real
quick yeah babies will be here in four
minutes
it's been four minutes where is he
fam
just cancelled the
there's nothing you can do there is
literally not it's so annoying bro and
you know i'll just get another one and
the thing's just blinking
fam mine mine has gone on a madness
recently if i do um confirm or whatever
um the the map will just ping off to one
place and then ping off to another place
it does a [ __ ] before he even ever
finds a car that's an absolutely funny
pray to you never try and get an uber
from senpai chris
i don't think i ever will i don't i
never land
yeah i always do that's my go-to station
yeah it's impossible
it's impossible i'm pretty sure
the black cabs have a monopoly in that
area i'll swear
because there's thousands of them yeah
and ubers just aren't picking up yeah
they're like [ __ ] they're just canceling
trips left right and center they're not
about it yeah yeah so there's the yeah
that's their territory
right
oh one more
when he unfollows insta models when they
get a man
i'm not going to lie sometimes you get
lost in the fairy tale you do you do
everyone does you have to get lost in it
and if you're not going to get lost in
it then what's the point it's the point
yeah so yeah let me get lost in it of
course that happens uh yes but what's
also double edged about what she just
what she just wrote is that how does she
know
yeah obviously she's pretty and she's
the whole team pre and him to see who
he's following then realized oh he's not
following this chick anymore let me go
see why yeah yeah she's doing the
ickiest due diligence you can do
but she don't care i know she doesn't
yeah she don't care doesn't she doesn't
come off as yeah because
she's the main character in her little
movie
so she can do the antagonist we're
always a protagonist and we're just
[ __ ] villains all the time bro
literally he's [ __ ] dead that's
hilarious um just
excuse me
just before because i know you've got a
video you want to show me yeah just
before that yeah
quick movie recommendation okay you
might have seen it okay spider head
okay
you liked it no no no so what happened
was i started watching it
yesterday or maybe two days ago but i
was so in and out of sleep
that
i didn't grasp the whole thing but i
also watched the trailer maybe a day or
two before that and i thought oh the
cast looks good the cast is good and i
was like
yeah then i then today i think on the
train down here i was seeing poor
reviews after poor review oh really yeah
i didn't i liked it
on rotten tomorrow and i was like
okay
fair enough but i've not when i watched
the trailer
i was expecting hype because of the cost
yeah yeah yeah and the trailer didn't
really move me um and obviously me not
finishing a movie and me seeing these
bad reviews i'm thinking oh maybe it's
not a good movie yeah yeah yeah yeah so
i couldn't hit me i can see why people
so i watched it yesterday yeah so
for a sunday evening chill watch perfect
okay
would i have ever gone to the cinema to
watch it hell no that says a lot it does
say a lot but it doesn't make it a bad
movie it just doesn't make it a cinema
movie
very true like for example um
people are rating
this new topic i haven't seen it yeah
we'll see it okay
people are saying it's like 15 out of
10. bro people are saying something it's
the best movie they've ever seen yep yep
i've heard at the beginning of the movie
tom cruise does this little speech and
basically says like the movie was
finished like three four years ago but
cinemas were closed due to kovacs they
delayed the team because you have to
watch this thing in a cinema you can't
watch it at home yeah you're not gonna
get it at home you have to be here yeah
you need the surround side you need the
experience of the cinema and it's not
gonna be as good if you watch our home
so we needed to make sure everyone could
go see it in the cinema yeah
that's like the reverse of this movie
same with like um that adam sandler's
hustle yeah i don't want to watch if i
watch that in the cinema i would have
been last cool movie but
i'm not it's not a movie i want to leave
my house and pay money and go and see
i'm with you it's a movie that i enjoyed
more because of the surroundings that i
was in yeah and it was an unexpected
delight
do you know what i mean
i was already chilling minding my
business yeah and it just so happened to
be
a welcome addition to my evening that's
what spider head is okay it's a very
weird take on a movie it's a very unique
take on a movie which is good
they execute what i like about the movie
right it's um
a completely different light than what
we've seen chris hemsworth do before
does he pull it off
kind of in parts he really pulls it off
in other parts he's too far that way
you'll know when you see the move like
he's very quirky okay and very like
energetic but it's all
like
a two-faced lie okay and he's not really
that kind of person but he has to act up
to be this way all the time and you can
see what he's trying to do and there's
certain parts of the film you like
[ __ ] this guy's a good manipulator like
[ __ ] hell he's good and he really
does a really good job actually does
show quite a bit of range to chris like
hemsworth like repertoire um as an actor
and i'll show you he actually can act
okay because the
his mission in this film
is to get people to think he's his
friend he's their friend and he does
that brilliantly yeah but then there's
other parts of the movie i won't spoil
it because other parts of the movie was
doing some other [ __ ] weren't you a bit
like
uh
it's just too much now you're just
you're doing too much okay there's bits
in that movie where chris hans are doing
too much the premise did you know
actually what the actual premise is
to be fair i can't remember i just know
they're in some physics i think they're
like a prison like a prison facility so
yeah so basically for guys who don't
know spider head is it's based on like a
uh i'm sure it was based on a novel as
well i think uh or like a short story or
something um spider head is
a film where
they live in a world where basically
there is this prison where prisoners
from like general population prisons can
apply to be a part of but they're
basically lab rats so it's a
pharmaceutical testing center
it reminds me so it's like it reminds me
of a
series that i started watching on
netflix that i never even finished
because i got this interested in called
i think it's called maniac with john
hill and
her face in my head but i can't remember
it's somewhat like a lab rat drug type
of test thing so that's i was comparing
the two when i started watching it but
remind me of that but continue anyway
so
basically chris hemsworth runs his
prison and he's creating all these drugs
that he wants them to go mainstream and
he tests them on these prisoners
and they've basically signed up for this
and in in reward for being part of this
like program is that their prison is
chill as [ __ ] yeah there's no cells
there's no like they get to go outside
they can have relationships with other
prisoners it's like
male and female like
everything's blessed they get to cook
nice food they get to basically do
whatever they want
as long as some space yes within this
space because it's on like a deserted
island at the middle of nowhere they
can't escape if they wanted to okay
but within these like parameters they
can do what they want and it's like it's
a great way as a prisoner is a great way
to live your life
sort of but then they also have to be
like subjects for these drugs that they
test and like some of the drugs are like
like some of the drugs are like um
severe agitators so stuff like
they're just like this [ __ ] burning
spray that you put on my neck like
imagine that as a drug oh wow you put in
your blood oh wow like it drives people
crazy it's so agitating and painful for
them and like they have to be tests for
that they have to be tested like these
sex drugs
um
that like that make you fall in love
with someone and like yeah so as you're
saying it's coming back to me now
because i remember bits of him obviously
i don't want to spoil it people haven't
watched it but i remember certain bits
where they took a drug and
hit uh miles teller and some other chick
they were they were getting involved
yeah yeah yeah yeah and then he asked
them afterwards is it because you love
her and stuff like that yeah yeah
because i'm like so yeah they're testing
all these drugs and basically the story
unravels from there i will say is it the
best movie i've seen this year
definitely not
is it a new take on a movie that i liked
the idea of definitely okay definitely
worth a watch anyone who says not worth
watching is an idiot
because the acting is good the cars are
good
um the story is good like there's no
they're just good it's just not an
amazing movie it's just a good movie to
watch on netflix okay i'll give it a go
this week but yeah i i liked it [ __ ] the
[ __ ] rotten tomatoes guys we're gonna
take a very quick break to have a little
chat about
below the waist grooming
we're going to shed some
knowledge some love
over at the good people at man escaped
obviously specifically focusing on their
performance package 4.0
okay inside this package guys we've said
it before we're going to say it again
you're going to find the lawn mower 4.0
this is the trimmer
we've got the weed whacker ear and nose
hair trimmer we've got the crop
preserver ball deodorant ball deodorant
guys you didn't even know that was a
ting until we just said it
ball deodorant and crop reviver toner
yeah mom
lest we say more
yes we shall
performance boxer briefs on top of that
that's a little bonus best box is going
best boxes going bro you feel like mr
incredible in these boxes frozone just
aha where's my super suit
where's
get yourself some super suit boxes
um and a cheeky little travel bag inside
the performance package 4.0 guys so what
you need to do is
run on over to manscape.com
use the code sng sierra november golf
and you're going to snag yourself 20 off
and free shipping one more time from the
top manscape.com the code you want to
use is sng so you're november golf come
on
and get yourself 20 off and free
shipping worldwide
without any further ado let's get back
to talking smack
thank you for listening
um but yeah you have some video thing
yeah so in um
in correlation to
the
um
celebrity like boxing matches we've been
talking about yes yes yes yes yes um
episodes also
that i saw a random video on twitter
um
blac chyna
versus
alicia megan
and i don't know who the [ __ ] is
elizabeth
no
i did it's a brutal it was a celebrity
boxing match i'm gonna read you
a little a little synopsis but i don't
even know as to why this match even took
place
so that's happened this this actually
have actually never read i'm just going
to show you the video bro
this happened like live
[Music]
oh this is
oh that was the ugliest thing i've ever
seen oh like what's the point what
literally is it's probably bragging
rights because
i'm assuming let me actually find out
who alicia
megan is
because i i don't even see the
correlation i don't understand why they
had this fight who they are
and
yeah it was just
i think it was just one of them ones
where
celebrities just want to have it out
because they've been chatting [ __ ] with
each other obviously they've passed away
yeah why can't they have it out like
proper people like on road
proper people
what's all this boxing match stuff
i guess like scrap me on roads it's the
trend i guess it's the trend but it's
just dead bro like stuff that's
embarrassing that was the worst fight
i've ever seen in my life she's a
fitness model
is she paying i bet she is paying uh she
looks decent
um let me check out instagram actually
but yeah that's a ick for me it just the
female the female celebrity boxing
matches the male ones if yeah it would
be a nick as well they are to be fair
even as a guy to me they're an ick
um that's the other trick but yeah
that's like
pathetic
of course she is very pain to be fair
but yeah like
so pointless so pointless and stupid
very pointless
oh that's so embarrassing bro
that's actually so embarrassing people
are hyper up like it's like the worst
thing of all time i just don't
understand why guys girls
people celebrities
out there whoever's listening ah she's
bad as well guys jesus christ what don't
settle beefs
with celebrity boxing matches yeah
literally dies it's just why like it's
just don't do it
just have it out like normal human
beings it doesn't have to be televised
it doesn't have to be it's a body oddie
in it
[ __ ] you now
you're still at this girl you're just
rolling through just pick this video
this face-off thing this little this
promo team this little sizzle reel
sizzle reel let me see i haven't even
read it that's the letter yeah
yeah this they're bodied up both of them
both of them are for sure
for sure
yeah rob kardashian just buried nuts and
earned it yeah he just i i don't blame
him
but [ __ ] hell and uh tiger tiger yeah
oh god tiger berries nuts in everyone
[ __ ] tiger's such tiger's such a weird
celebrity to me
explain he just literally just
he
he doesn't do much
but he's like the most relevantly
relevant
he really doesn't do much in the scheme
of things anymore
like i would say
from circa 2000 and
maybe 10
till about 2 000 and
no i'd say like 13. really i think he
maybe not 10 to 15 uh maybe not 10 to 13
but i would never say that he had
uh
he did not have more than three years at
the level oh yeah yeah no no no no but
like in terms of his relevance i would
say maybe from 2010 too in my opinion
because i listen to him a lot more after
he's mainstream stuff as well oh okay
yeah um at the time
so yeah i would say around especially
because that's when fan of a fan two
came out blah blah you know
so i'll definitely say from ten to
fifteen or ten after the fan of a fan
two his career plummeted it did plummet
it did plummet doesn't make sense i
think it was well i say i think i have
no [ __ ] clue um but obviously a lot
of the stuff with
um him in black chyna then obviously
blac chyna and rob and him and the
kardashian family all that [ __ ] happened
um he's
i don't know to be fair so who yeah all
of the rest of them apart from rob but
rob's never been doing anything with his
life apart from rob the rest of them
doing fine obviously that china's not
yeah but again she's fighting for money
yeah
she's literally fighting she's scrapping
hoes in a boxing ring her life is
terrible yeah but yeah tiger has no
reason he just started just he did
nothing for ages and then just like bits
and bobs here and there and then just
like pulling his dick out on only fans
he makes bags of only fans of her does
he i've heard he mixed bags on only fans
as i'm saying he's the most relevant
irrelevant person he's like why is tiger
making cash on only fans it doesn't make
any sense
[ __ ] hell
[ __ ] out i never knew he was on only
fans anyway apparently he's got a hog on
him
i'm not gonna lie to you bro apparently
he's got a [ __ ] hog on him maybe
that's why he's staying relevant b
maybe that is why he's staying ready it
is clearly but yeah it's random that is
random yeah blac chyna all this they're
both lengthenings we can sort this out a
different way a completely different way
we don't need to be boxing yes on camera
that
all of that was appalling yeah the whole
the whole thing was appalling it was
[ __ ] it was no man and she was uh
blac chyna was punching the chick after
the bar rang as well just trying to get
a few few knocks in but yeah but your
your knocks are pathetic
the way they were the power that they
were punching with one of them could
have just stood there like it's just
like and it's not doing anything the ref
was just there like yeah the ref was
that i couldn't fake that i couldn't
fake that energy i don't care what
you're paying me i can't fake this this
is stupid yeah guys stop stop boxing man
yeah that johnny's got use as well man
just give it a rest
just give it a [ __ ] i can no one can
tell me my mom's doing that
facts
facts and both you so of cognitive
ability to understand lag one fam
no one could tell me
i seen your mum fighting some porn star
looking yeah
on camera the other day
at school um and she was getting time to
pieces she was up in the corner just
protecting her [ __ ] ears bro
she got dropped yeah your mom got
[ __ ] rocked yesterday yeah yeah
you know [ __ ] yeah they're all [ __ ]
like your mom bully you oh they're gonna
bully you you're paying mum with a fat
ass she got rocked by some other hoe
it's embarrassing this is how you're
almost paying bills
this is how you're most paying bills
tiger would have to stop yeah he would
have to stop it that's that's what i'm
called for yeah it is uncool for but
that's a dread thing as well because
toggle gets smacked up as well
he's like this cycle gets smacked oh
he's paper thin man yeah so it's the
whole family's
just a ruckus yeah yeah
robin doing nothing to no one either
he's lost mad weight though has he he's
lost man he needed to yeah he was he was
he was a big dangerous territory
he was in dangerous waters he was going
through stuff
he was going for he was going through
yeah you're
all of your sisters they keep coming and
every single one of them is the most
famous slag in the world
they keep coming he was going you keep
having new sisters and every single one
is the biggest most famous hoe on planet
earth and they all make more money than
you all of them make more money than him
you're from your mum
to your stepmom
to
your step to your mom to your stepmom to
all five of your sisters
all of them make bags and all of them
suck dick
famously
famously yeah yeah it must be tough no
wonder he turned into a fat mess yeah
he's just not on it's just i would i
couldn't live like that i couldn't
either there's too much estrogen yeah
too much easter yeah yeah
oh goodness bless him yeah and then your
your brother-in-law is just
just doing up clubs doing up close and
being a baller yeah
before you could tap into that yeah
he saw scott just living
he's cause he's got this guy and i was
like
what's going on why is he in a family
but he's just doing yeah he's doing the
damn thing he's balling out control it
doesn't make sense and i'm just here and
i'm just here and getting heavier and
heavier hardly getting scenes in the
show oh
he's just
these might just kept me walking through
the kitchen
on some blurred thing i ain't got two
lions this season these men just see me
walking in the backdrop yo
that's hilarious oh and then i've got
yeah blac chyna yanking my sperm
yanking it no one else in this show is
accidentally pregnant
facts
no one else in this thing is accidental
they haven't used who with who they want
how they when they were when they were
willy nilly
and i'm just here bang one painting she
drapes it from me drapes there and i'm
for life now and who who drape who
thought she was pregnant as well because
she's banging that other banging thing
that we used to follow the instagram
thing remember she's like dominican or
satin
back of back a day i'm pretty sure we
had a pregnancy scale with her i don't
remember oh i can't remember her name
for the live movie dominican light
skinting
she was an instagram model
i can't remember her name oh maybe
someone in the comments will tell me he
used to just do a thing with bad
instagram she was one of the og
instagram models back when instagram was
early i'm trying to think i can't
remember her name for the life of me if
you had oh that's annoying it might was
it like
did you remember r like a rosa rose
signed
um let me see um
i've got to do something we've always
done a thing with literally
everyone
wow
rosa acosta rosa acosta
bad buddy buddy wow
wow
wow
yeah yeah yeah it was on the show yeah
yeah i forgot about it she was an og ig
model
brady oh yeah she was filthy peg wow
rob yeah
yeah wow yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i'd i'd eat myself to death as well
well i lost that i'd eat myself into it
i thought he was going through stuff he
was going through [ __ ] oh god wow
yeah bro he could have held on to that
rosa acosta yeah yeah whoa bangington
woman
whole woman
that's a whole i need to look at
instagram now that's a hot i forgot she
existed yeah same bro wow i knew he i
knew i knew it yeah he definitely did a
thing with her that is hilarious yeah
she was oh bro she was one of the first
ig models i ever followed yeah
she was she
wow
baddie she must be old now okay i would
say old oh she's still fire oh for
crying out loud she's banging yeah she
is banging oh dear
oh my word she's banging oh she's more
banging now than she was there imagine
don't do that again oh my lord she's an
absolute
dime piece yeah she's um i'm surpri fam
rob kardashian yeah rokadashin was just
clapping her cheeks bro i remember she
was in an episode one time
wow
fairly [ __ ] wild wild type [ __ ]
play um
anyway
right just before we do the um
the ig questions yeah
my boy justin bieber's going through it
fam fam i saw like
20 seconds of a video about him having
some syndrome
why is that funny that's what he called
it no
it's called sighted sighted syndrome is
it not
where harvey's face is still and the
other half is drooping
some syndrome
[Laughter]
was it not it was it was it was i can't
remember what the syndrome is called but
apparently some virus got fam
he's going through it because the way
the ting
did what it did to him
doesn't make scientific sense to me and
he's gonna chat like it's normal yeah
and i'm hearing it i'm thinking am i
hearing it different to what he's saying
because what i heard is he caught a
virus that went in his ear and pinched a
nerve and half of his face was paralyzed
a virus like the flu
like chicken pox what's pinching nerves
what's all this chats that's not yeah
that's not scientific yeah i was
thinking do you mean parasite
is there an insect in there yeah like
virus in your ear
dropping faces
that's not a disease we've heard of and
these men are just just brisking through
the conversation i
wouldn't understand the science i'm so
the thing is i'm actually surprised
because i saw that video once and didn't
see any news blog or anything i saw
nothing else about it it came out
you know what's dread as well
and i saw it because i had heard about
it and i'd seen on on like instagram and
twitter that like oh justin bieber's
face is [ __ ] paralyzed or whatever
and then he came out and did the video
and for the first like five seconds i'm
like there's nothing wrong with his face
i don't understand he's like as you can
see like my face is paralyzed and stuff
and i'm like no it's not and then he
blinks he's in the blink
i saw it briefly i remember when he
blinks one eye blinks like that and the
other one goes like this
it goes up like that this face says
it'll blink and then it'll go
and i was like oh
no oh my god
bro oh i know he's a religious man he
doesn't deserve this and i promise you
i'd lose i'd lose faith in in god in
humanity and everything big big justin
bieber paralyzed face these men don't
know how long it lasts yeah they say
it's curable but they don't know until
when
oh i promise you now wow
if that happened to me i'd be so bitter
i'd be like um
i'd be like
do you remember we spoke about this a
lot ago two-face in the batman movie
what does he say when he turns around i
can't [ __ ] remember but he turns out
he's such vigor and he's vexed yeah
shaking in the hospital bed that would
be me if i had this virus thing this
syndrome you're a prick and you man came
to see me
i know and then you could only see the
side of the face that worked i'm looking
up wait wait wait
i'm looking up
i'm looking straight up and you might
come and see me i don't look at you you
come in the door from the right yeah and
you're like james i heard you got a
virus in like yeah i have still yeah
yeah i like that yeah you look normal
still you look calm do i yeah bro like
what did they say is wrong with you
what do you think's wrong with me
i'll do that and all you'd see is the
blink
i'll turn around like what do you think
is wrong with me and you'll think i
don't see anything wrong over
i'll do that sticky blink
my eye just deplete that big
and you're like oh [ __ ]
i'll take two steps back i'm not gonna
lie
if you turn your head
shaking and you did like a blink blink i
would take two steps back
i'll whisper nurse
nurse
he needs help he needs help
i'll be vexed
i said i'd be so bitter
i'll be [ __ ] angry that's hilarious
oh
they couldn't tell me we don't know how
long it's going to be like this yo tell
me if i'm an international superstar
tell me
figure it the [ __ ] out
he's so oh he's lucky he's i got caught
banging brazilian prostitutes and live
my life to the epitome yeah and now i've
been living by god's word for years
for years i've settled down true i'm
doing true pro bono videos for drake
like
what more can i do
what literally more can i do and you're
just [ __ ] with my face
nah [ __ ] you fix it
i've got all the money in the world fix
it literally take the virus out my ear
you're chatting you're just saying stuff
i'm justin bieber yeah fix it
[ __ ] sake i might tell you if i was
just i'll be going back to the brazilian
bieber
bring back brazilian b but that's what i
say the four b's
bring back brazilian bible because
paralyzed you know oh but anyways let's
do ig questions um right guys as you
know um every week we ask you a question
and this week we asked you
what lengths have you gone through to
sleep with someone and as per usual guys
juicy ass responses
let me go let's go i'll just compose
myself yeah yeah
um
what's it called again what lengths have
you gone to sleep with someone yeah oh
jesus all right i'm ready cool walked
two kilometers at 3am drunk as [ __ ] just
to go to a party he was at all for the
one short round oh
of course it was going to be a short
round of go who are we kidding two weeks
three a.m party yeah he's gonna not he's
gonna bang you in the toilet and just
carry on with his boys that's it
that's it it's your fault
paid 50 pounds for for a taxi to his
had to wait for him to arrive he gave me
chlamydia
[Music]
dreads
dread i'm surprised that these that's
two women i'm surprised about that bro
they they come home fast but the women
came
pretended to be her gay best friend in
front of her husband i even dyed my hair
pink
[Laughter]
how long is this play fam how long is
this play
wow
drove 112 miles for him to say his own
name during sex
wow
do you know how far 112 miles is
it's a few hours
it's a few [ __ ] hours
yes it is that's like two and a half
hours three hours to say his own name
during the deed
that's long
in order to infiltrate the friendship
group i had to binge watch gossip go and
vampire diaries
remind me of jacob yeah jacob's a story
about what was it called girls girls he
got two seasons deep into gilmore girls
before he was watching the wrong thing
i would throw my laptop have you seen
gilmore girls oh wow it's the worst show
that's how i know he's a true [ __ ]
friend but it's the worst show there
isn't a worse show than that
it's like little house on the prairie
but like
with a single mom oh my goodness it's
awful [ __ ] it out
ah all right
join the chris
joined the christian fellowship
attending weekly bible readings turned
out he was gay
oh that's a plot twist there's a plot
twist and a half
flown halfway across the world at my
expense i thought we were engaged he was
also engaged too
[Laughter]
wow
convince the girl i was bawling because
i saved up
so she let me smash and then she caught
me on the bus
imagine
imagine
i've saved up i'm doing so much i'm
balling buying this buying that just to
impress her
and she caught me on the bus she's let
me nut the night before
on the bus
i wouldn't be able to break eye contact
wait if you're gonna go no
yeah and i'm sitting there just chilling
and i see her walk on the bus once i've
looked up and and seen her
and i've seen her see me
i wouldn't be able to like
stop looking at her
i'll be frozen if you had [ __ ]
oh that's peak
ah
gone uber to the club to pick him up and
bring him back to mine and to make sure
he didn't go home
oh that's desperate that is very that's
desperate wow i'm surprised about those
you know what yeah this is good that the
women are we needed this yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah these women are chatting the
most the most like oh he did this all
this oh he did this for me i made him do
this when he was doing coursework for me
i didn't even let him smash
i was he was doing all this for me the
[ __ ] idiot he was driving him here
picking me up from work he was dropping
me there cooking me food bro all these
men are moving stupid stupid turns out
he was engaged too yeah gang gang
went to went to her church for five
months even became an usher met her
family i was focused
wow that's
a lot i'm not doing anything i'm not
doing anything
there's certain stories that we've read
on this show before where i'm like i
don't think i enjoy sex that much yeah
jeremy
is there something wrong with it because
i love it yeah i wouldn't dream of any
of these things i was focused
five months did he say
where's the end goal
after you not what happens then yeah
what happens then he's just not going
church anymore are you not going to be
in usher anymore yeah yeah they know who
you are bro you're part of the community
now [ __ ] me man some people take it too
far yeah yeah yeah
told him we could date he still sends me
paragraphs at 4 a.m
[Music]
dear [ __ ] you know decorated my friend's
house like a restaurant made menus and
signs i got my pal to dress up as a
waiter
i promise you now james
listen to me i promise you now i can't
walk into a girl's yard
and her have her whole thing done up
like a restaurant
tables chairs the works candles music
whatever and then her bredrin is our
waiter and she's all like she's like
she's got the airplane
little dick here's our menu did you like
some bread
big man and the yes you're staring me in
my face i'll flip the table how much
money have you wasted on this
where do your priorities lie
i said i'm coming over to just have some
food
and this is what you're doing
[Laughter]
she's got everything backwards
where the [ __ ] do your priorities like
order a chinese and put a tea for you
because you're just chatting
[ __ ] off tell your friend to [ __ ] off
what is this
foolish
how dare you like what is this what is
this this is so embarrassing
like i'm not
i'm less likely to [ __ ] you now oh rags
hope you know rags thank you for wasting
both our time
that's what i'll say to her [ __ ] me
drove 30 minutes to his work for sex
while he was on his break oh my god
that's
that's on some raunchy [ __ ] bro she must
have sent him a new like mid day get
here now get my
[ __ ] lunch breaks out one get here
now cheeks ready
clapped and he went straight back
just a lucas a to hydrate and i finished
this for some electrolytes and just
carried on harry just powered through
the rest of it oh that's fantastic ah
that's that's when you know you're
you're having sex they're in a honeymoon
yeah honeymoon that's a honeymoon having
sex
i miss her i missed the last train home
after a date and didn't want to pay for
the cab
so we ended up staying
did it
family read this one and felt her pain
oh come on come on god
reposted his soundcloud tracks with the
fire emojis
that's the most no no
no that that's the leg
that's wow
just to get some clothes out tracks
with the fire emojis
that's
humiliating
i promise you now you could not be
chatting to a thing who's a soundcloud
artist yeah
and you're telling me you're you're
caught in this yeah yeah
and i see you post her [ __ ] with
i i'm saying fam
you either block her or i'm blocking you
i don't said i'm courting this yet
i don't want to see that behavior bro
sound cloud that's humiliating
oh if i say who's this chick if i ever
saw you do that you best send me rosa
acosta yeah
say you best send me rosacea because if
i see anyone that's not benga or that
level yeah i've lost boys
yes i've lost my mind that's the only
answer
oh [ __ ] hell
sat on his bed while he played the
guitar and sang it was awkward as [ __ ]
oh my god do you remember that um i'm
too hot to handle when patrick did that
to someone who
in australia
yeah tigs and eyes i can't remember a
name for the margaret robbie yeah yes oh
she was she was tidy yeah she was not
feeling that whatsoever he just made
that song up on the spot on the car he
was just saying
i love your blue eyes yeah
[ __ ] i love your blue eyes [ __ ]
promised her a free nutritional diet
plan i wasn't even a nutritionist
googled i'm pretending like i was oh bro
i know bear man i've done that
man i've done that
there was a breath at the gym i used to
work at
he was notorious for just saying he was
a pt he wasn't where he was
if you saw a thing that he liked
he just man said it as if he had a
wanted post
on every gym
he's notorious he got banned
he got banned from there
he was notorious for it bro
[Laughter]
if he saw cheeks that he liked yeah he
just randomly rock up to ya while she's
doing like this thing yeah the abductors
yeah just say do you want some personal
training
i should be like
[ __ ]
you don't you're wearing the uniform or
anything he's like yeah i'm a freelance
jaw's a personal trainer yes or no chest
just for personal training or not
notorious
wow what personal training or not that's
hilarious
the amount of chicks that came out to be
like
does he work here and i'm like no
he keeps asking if i want personal
training
he's [ __ ] harassing me but it was too
funny but yeah he had to go
wow oh god gave my mum sleeping pills
so i could sneak him in
she was very light sleeper i had to
[ __ ] hell
jesus christ
sleeping pills that's too much
played the gay best friend that was
interested in testing my sexuality oh
wow i wonder how
these fam
this day and age like that's defined as
rape bro that is rape that has to be
raped
that has to be raped
it is because it's there's not it's [ __ ]
like that it's wild too bro it is wild
to me
i said it i'll say it again i don't
think i like sex enough
yeah because these men are on stuff
they're onstars
logic yeah
told my boyfriend at the time in
bracket's current husband now that i was
doing overtime but i was really [ __ ]
she married this man she married she was
just cheating on haphazardly cheating on
wow
answer the door bought us naked when
they came to pick up their when they
came to pick me up for the first date
that was the girl that sent that i've
got i don't know it is because if it was
a guy it's never gonna pan out yeah it's
never gonna make it to this list yeah
yeah it's never gonna work and i knew i
know for a fact it worked for her and
it's so frustrating yeah obviously i
would guess it happened to me but like
it's just so frustrating that it would
just work it would
i think
i'll be gassed overall yes but i think
if she opened or i opened or whatever
and first date i'm coming to pick her up
and she's just naked i wouldn't know
what to expect i don't think i know what
to do
because i wouldn't be expecting it yeah
i know i would i know what to do oh
don't get me wrong i would know what to
do but it's like
i think i'd freeze for a second
yeah it would be
so far left
i've got
reservations do you know what i mean
i've got reservations i've come to pick
you up free like you said we've got
reservations love i just filled up my
tank literally is teeth
like i'm dressed
and your hair obviously don't get me
wrong you're starting
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you're banging
yes but like
this is the dread thing right this is
listen listen
it sucks because
in a girl's mind
she might be thinking right
he's gonna come here i'm gonna open the
door butt naked he's gonna come in he's
gonna [ __ ] the shower me then we can go
on our date no no no no no sweetheart
i'm not doing anything after riding
and i'm going home this is our first
date now
so whatever you had in your head love
you're done it's literally done it's
done for a guy like i said like once it
gets from here to here it's done it's
done it's done i'm banging and i'm going
home and i'm like that was cool that was
a very nice but then yeah i'm vic's i
wasted the reservations especially if i
had to pay a deposit
because a guy orchestrates all this
stuff to try and impress you to hope he
can nut so when he's built all this
infrastructure and realized you as soon
as you open the door he see titty titty
pom he's like
i just wasted all my time i've literally
wasted all my i've got she could have
told me to just come home over and [ __ ]
like
i made plans yeah but obviously i'm
going to go in there and crack the [ __ ]
out of this of course of course of
course but yeah it would it's
it'll be like a yeah
that's why i said at first i'll freeze
but obviously afterwards i'll give you a
thing
telling him i was a virgin them boys in
christ love that [ __ ]
wow
that's a devil girl that's a little
devil girl [ __ ] hell
i lied that's naughty family
jail time
stalked her for ages she was so shocked
we had so much in common oh my god
on a youtube nah
oh my goodness man didn't do that oh
i've met man that do that i swear yeah
i'll tell you off camera oh swear yeah
yeah okay
i know people oh man say less yeah yeah
yeah they don't see anything wrong with
it
wow they were so shocked got so much in
common
that's
manipulation that's my stalk to her for
ages
what's ages fam he didn't give me time
reference
wow
i went three years without him going
down on me
this is the most she did for sex
she's a fool apparently she's a fool
yeah she's definitely full
changed religion for a month oh god
drove 30 minutes only to give a hand job
then after he told me he wanted to be
friends
[Laughter]
there can't be anything
worse
than being a girl and just giving a guy
a hand job
what else are you doing if you're just
giving a handy j
what there's nothing to do with romance
the guys who said ah
i [ __ ] won't be i know you hate it i
[ __ ] hate it
i'll be looking out like you're finished
[Music]
oh there can't be anything worse than
just giving a hand job and not getting
banged just
yeah bro it's um yeah [ __ ] that anyway
dude came to brazil from the uk for two
weeks and he didn't get any i warned him
i wanted him warned him don't get on
this flight if you think you're clapping
cheeks because i promise you you're not
he said i am two weeks i'm coming [ __ ]
i am i'm coming from the americas to you
and i'm not [ __ ] i promise you i am
man said i warned him
he he thought it was all foreplay
he thought it was this whole i'm not
that kind of girl chat
but if man's getting on a flight an
18-hour flight oh it's happening i'm
touching cheeks
she said i warned him [ __ ] i'd be so
angry jay i'd
i wouldn't even know what to do
you can't be angry at anyone but
yourself yeah facts facts facts
the warnings for two weeks
that's too long two weeks i've spent
every day with you for two weeks i don't
care what warnings you gave me
what's gay or not
are you interested in me or not
because i can get a return flight home
tomorrow yeah right this is what we're
doing right
right i'm not waiting the whole two
weeks yeah yeah you [ __ ] up
oh my god
took her to her hotel said i could do
anything as long as i let her pee on me
then sit on my face
ugh
would you would you
would you let go not to sit in the face
thing would you let go piss on you if
she said you could do anything
it depends on because i was thinking
about that after i read this
it depends on
like my
what's my positioning like
am i laying down on a bed and she's
pissing on me most likely am i
i don't know am i
kneeling down i don't know because i
feel like with
if it's raw reverse if i'm the guy
pissing on a girl
it's somewhat sexy because she's near my
dick anyway if she's giving me head like
i see it as a more sexual actor okay
obviously yeah because i'm the one doing
as opposed to receiving it
okay what if she is
what if she plays it off like it's a
squirting thing so
you're laying on you're laying on the
bed not plays it off but you know she's
going to piss on you but it's very
sexual as what i'm saying like so you're
laying down
um arse naked she's just above your
waist so she's like
um
let's say she's sat up so she's sat up
on your thighs knees like this pump here
your tool's just here yeah yeah and then
she's flicking being licking and sliding
on the teeth yeah ashy nuts she just
pisses on you
but
okay two questions well one question one
statement nut is piss anyway
yeah yeah i know so it's safe i know
well not same same but same sex yeah i
know second an actual question is this
happening
is she pissing on me and then i can do
whatever i want or can i do what i want
then she pisses on me because that's
it's important
she has to piss on you first oh [ __ ] no
because if i'm doing this for your
benefit because if you've already done
whatever you want i promise you you're
not gonna let piss on you
i'd fight her
i'd [ __ ] fight her you'll be sitting
there soft as a sponge
soft as a wet sponge
and she's just doing the most
you'll be thinking what on earth is
happening to me that said i'm doing it
for your own
trust i'm doing this for your benefit
she has to piss on you first and then
you go have a shower as soon as you get
out the shower she's ready he says do
what you want to me all right
but yeah i would i would [ __ ] it i would
rack [ __ ] it [ __ ] you [ __ ] it
i convinced her i was i convinced her i
was my own twin to sleep with her again
new tattoos and [ __ ] and it worked
that makes no sense
he got new tattoos to say he was his
twin brother
that's the most he's done apparently to
sleep with someone wow
was she that repulsed by you that she
didn't want to [ __ ] you again
do you have to lie about your identity
did she not clock that you had exactly
the same tattoos on top of new tattoos
yes
that's dumb
bought him a car during the pandemic
when he when he was working as a
delivery guy because he didn't want to
get he didn't want to increase the
mileage on his bmw that i had paid for
that paid for the deposit when he got
the finance the same bmw he crashed on
his way home from cheating on me
[Laughter]
this one is cracked okay this one's
great
followed and put a notification bell on
insta accounts i know that he loves so i
can like the posts first
wow man what are we doing that's
intuitive just to
just so he can see that she's alive
we like the same [ __ ] [ __ ] hell man
this is basically she basically yeah
she's doing this talking to doing a
stalking tank but on a that's level on a
legitimate yeah yeah
on a legal way exactly yeah planted
drugs on an ex to get him deported
no listen to me james
i what's that got to do with getting sex
by the way they just said that they just
they just wanted a confession
is there a part two
so then once he was deported i could
carry on my life my assumption is
um
he she's he's obviously likes this chick
that was always got a man so now that
he's deported he's the ex so he's now
doing a thing with her
oh you think a guy did that
no no no no say that again what did you
just say your synopsis is my synopsis
so
let's say let's say i'm the guy that got
deployed right yeah and you're the new
ting you're the new brother with the
chick yeah so you planted uh drugs on me
so me and this girl were together you
planted drugs with me because i'm
deployed i'm obviously now the x they're
not together anymore so you can bang so
it was a guy that wrote that to you
yes a guy wrote planted drugs on her ex
to get i didn't even hear that properly
yeah i
i thought it was the girl saying planted
drugs on my ex to get him deported like
say i just hate this guy that's why i
was like what's that gonna do with sex
you're just deporting people on her ex
yeah
he
he
planted drugs on her boyfriend
to get him out of this country and out
of the picture
basically yeah wow yeah bro
bro yeah
that's probably top three that's along
with the yacht that tried to murder her
boyfriend oh the vomiting yeah oh my
that was the bleach and flashing that
was a confession oh my word
wow wow wow
um right give me one or two more cool
let me try and find cause i've got a few
wanted to make her mma fighting ex
jealous mma fighting wanted to make her
mma fighter x jealous i agreed thank god
he didn't care
[Laughter]
[Music]
[ __ ] you now
uh
i convinced the guy that both my friend
and i liked that she was mentally
unstable
wrong with people bro
i've never gone to anywhere near these
kind of lengths for anything
how do these people sleep at night bro
how does that deportation breath sleep
at night he nuts and kips bro yeah he he
nuts and he sleeps on silk sheets
entwined toes bro yeah just rubbing her
back
silk sheets [ __ ] hell right but yeah
guys that was
that was the ig question that was crazy
i really enjoyed this episode by the way
this is a long one but yeah i really
[ __ ] enjoyed it um as you said in the
beginning guys make sure you grab your
tickets come and see us live in
september of course catch us on thursday
on patreon uh we're having a whale of a
time and always guys love love love
[Music]